[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la crisis energética derivada de la
guerra de ucrania para ello me acompañan
tres invitados en este estudio mariana
castaño experto en comunicación
climática y fundadora de la consultora
de billion solutions bienvenida mariana
muchísimas gracias carlos un gusto estar
aquí compartiendo escenario con mis
colegas experto también euros.en manuel
rubio abogada especializada en energía
bienvenido a error hola carlos muchas
gracias carlos para internet
emilio de arriba ingeniero geofísico
especializado en geociencias energía
bienvenido emilio
la crisis energética a nuestro asunto de
hoy en primera plana
la onu ha señalado que la guerra en
ucrania es una crisis global dado el
impacto que está teniendo en los
mercados de energía o alimentos y que
grandes riesgos y las grandes riesgos
que plantea para muchos países los
expertos auguran que la escalada de los
precios puede acabar provocando incluso
estallidos sociales hoy centramos el
programa en una de esas crisis derivadas
de la guerra de putin la energética la
guerra de ucrania agita el fantasma de
la crisis petrolífera de los 70 y pone
de relieve la fragilidad de las
dependencias por ejemplo aquí en europa
europa es tremendamente dependiente del
petróleo y el gas rusos ambos
combustibles fósiles la crisis de
precios de la energía generada por la
guerra se suma al proceso de transición
energética haya emprendido por la unión
europea veremos sus efectos a partir de
ahora antes repasemos algunas portadas
que nos dejan la prensa internacional
sobre este asunto por ejemplo diario al
agua energía el reto de la seguridad
dice el diario que los consumidores
tienen un rol importante a jugar en esta
crisis vamos a hablar de hoy en el
programa
el precio de los carburantes trastorna
la vida de los franceses y también la
revista the economist power plate la
nueva era de las energías y la seguridad
la publicación enlaza ambos conceptos a
partir de ucrania bueno la inflación de
precios las dependencias energéticas la
geopolítica los objetivos de transición
energética estamos digamos marian ante
un tablero lleno de piezas en esta
crisis como lo estamos afrenta
afrontando qué riesgos oportunidades
desafíos puede salir de todo esto pues
estamos en una situación de crisis y a
las puertas de un choque internacional
un choque multisistémico porque ya se
está hablando del impacto que está
teniendo la subida del precio de los
combustibles en la subida del precio de
los alimentos estamos viendo la
inflación a nivel europeo se mantiene al
2% pero en países como españa y otros
países del sur está rondando el 10 por
ciento lo cual como tú decías abre el
riesgo a que haya conflicto conflictos
sociales y como en cada crisis como lo
vimos con la emergencia de la cob y del
19 hay una emergencia hay unas acciones
de emergencia para paliarlos
efectivamente y en este caso por
supuesto es evitar que la gente no pueda
poner la calefacción
ahora mismo veníamos hacia aquí y está
nevando en parís estamos casi en el mes
de abril es impresionante exactamente
entonces está muy bien pedirle a la
gente que baje el termostato en casa
pero hasta cierto ciertos límites sin
contar con aquellas personas que están
en pobreza energética que son muchos
millones de personas países del primer
mundo aquí en francia entonces yo
separaría las medidas de emergencia para
tratar de paliar los efectos a los más
vulnerables personas pero también
pequeñas y medianas empresas y unas
medidas más a largo plazo porque lo que
no podemos hacer es querer salir de una
crisis engordando la crisis climática y
al cabo la emergencia climática es el
trasfondo que vimos y con conexiones por
cierto en la crisis de la kobe 19 y en
esta crisis por supuesto que yo no
llamaría una crisis de los combustibles
fósiles rusos yo llamaría una crisis de
los combustibles fósiles generar en
general hay que eliminar la dependencia
de los combustibles lo que pasa es lo
hablaremos pero los planes a lo mejor la
urgencia desplaza bastante no el tema de
la transición a lo mejor no nos
acordamos lo suficiente porque la
urgencia bueno lo dice la propia palabra
no sé cómo lo ven la guerra de ucrania
no ha hecho más que poner quizás de
relieve la las dependencias todo el
entramado depende dependencia energético
que teníamos aquí en europa por hoy no
es fácil encontrar una posición común en
europa común porque la proporción de gas
en el mix energético por país así como
la proporción de este gas importado de
rusia varía según los países alemania e
italia son los países europeos más de
variantes de riesgo ruso en el caso de
la francia el que suda francia es
bastante diferente un tercio de las
importaciones francesa proviene de
noruega hay países más dependientes como
es el caso de alemania o de italia y
casos de países menos dependientes pero
en cualquier caso si queremos un
entramado de dependencias que es quizás
lo que ponga de relieve toda esta
situación y esta crisis energética
emilio al final si hablamos de países
como alemania italia ciertamente los
vemos bastante y dependientes de lo que
es el el gas y el petróleo brent el ruso
pero también está el carbón ruso europa
también tiene aproximadamente un
40% de importaciones de carbón de rusia
e incluso en francia podemos hablar del
20 por ciento de gas que viene de rossi
entonces ahorita no solamente se juega
el tema de dónde lo sacamos sino que
quién lo provee a qué costo y creo que
lo importante es no dejarnos llevar por
la inmediatez hay un camino que se ha
estado tratando durante varios años el
kit horita nos desesperamos y queremos
tomar medidas como decimos a lo loco
probablemente no está el mejor resultado
hay que ver ciertamente en el corto y en
el largo plazo para tener las objetivos
y realmente claro claro porque desde el
comienzo de la guerra de ucrania hace ya
más de un mes muchas voces piden cortar
ese grifo del gas y de la dependent del
gas y del petróleo rusos pero claro
luego hay países más dependientes como
comentábamos con el caso de alemania
casado y tal y que dicen a ver si va a
ser peor el remedio que la enfermedad a
ver si para la economía va a ser va a
ser peor esto lo que parece claro
mariana es que la geopolítica y la
energía están completamente conectados a
esta crisis muestra que la geopolítica y
la energía de repente eeuu vuelve a ser
amigo de venezuela vuelve a ser amigo de
irán los que éramos nuestros amigos son
nuestros enemigos como están conectadas
las dos piezas sí porque al final en el
tablero geopolítico mundial las piezas
son las que son las mimbres con las que
está hecho nuestro nuestro tejido social
y económico son los mismos
desgraciadamente la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles no se expone a que
este tipo de conflicto no haga
vulnerable ya estamos viendo esta mañana
salía en la noticia en países como sri
lanka porque hablamos de europa pero hay
que tener en cuenta que en europa
nuestro sistema del bienestar nos
protege ciertamente de determinadas
situaciones a pesar de como decía estar
con inflaciones que rondan el 10 por
ciento de sri lanka han tenido que tomar
medidas de urgencia y cortar la
electricidad del día durante 10 horas y
eso está provocando pues ya malestar
porque estamos hablando de gente que se
planifica muy corto a muy muy corto
plazo de tiempo ya lo vimos con la
pandemia en algunos países donde el
sistema de bienestar no es tan poderoso
como como en europa pues que los más
vulnerables fueron los que los que
pagaron el pato y estamos
desgraciadamente
antes hablaba de la comparación con el
choque petrolero petrolero de
1973 el mundo a día de hoy es muy
distinto está muchísimo más globalizado
con lo cual el efecto dominó de la
crisis de ucrania lo hemos estado viendo
desde el momento cero de que desde la
invasión de putin en ucrania y
desgraciadamente no hemos terminado de
ver las consecuencias de estos quería
preguntar este tema de se compara mucho
esta situación con la del choque
petrolero de los años 70 que similitudes
o que dice y qué diferencias bien
respecto a aquella situación o error de
hecho al ministro de economía francés
gureak comparó este crisis que
atravesamos con la crisis del petróleo y
los años 73 los dos crisis son
comparables en su intensidad su
brutalidad como en los años 73 los
precios de la energía ya de ser gasolina
gas van aumentando enormemente como en
los años 73 la búsqueda del desperdicio
de energía está en marcha la primera ley
francesa sobre la economía de energía
data de los años 74 pero aquí se acaba
la cooperación a las crisis que sufrimos
actualmente es diferente tiene su origen
tanto en la recuperación de la crisis
sanitaria de la cubeta como en la guerra
en ucrania pero no es enlace también con
la crisis sanitaria que antes también
hacía mariana entonces emilio sí que
podemos comparar en esa intensidad
respecto a los años 70 esa crisis pero
el contexto es completamente distinto y
también podríamos compararlo con la
primavera árabe que tienen un problema
con los con los precios el petróleo al
final esto solamente muestra lo endeble
que es el sistema lo endeble que es el
tejido en el que tenemos y la
dependencia que tenemos unos de otros al
final cualquier problema en otro país
que sea por ejemplo proveedor de gas y
petróleo termina repercutiendo en todo
el mundo no solamente en europa también
por ahora como lo decías en venezuela y
ahora resulta que bueno podría ser un
nuevo aliado después de haber estado los
últimos cinco años señalado como
enemigos
y
el enemigo era maduro los iraníes ahora
cuando la geopolítica no de repente los
intereses vascular para otro lado y el
que antes era nuestro enemigo pasa a ser
nuestro amigo entonces este cambio de
cromos no humano de venezuela ya no era
ya no son tan buenos de los derechos
humanos ya en este puzzle bastan otra
vida quizá tú de todo lo que estamos
hablando lo que pone de manifiesto es
que esta es una muestra de la necesidad
de acelerar la diversificación de las
fuentes energéticas que ayuden a
contrarrestar la demanda ya su vez sean
más limpias para ayudar al medio
ambiente eso es lo que muestra todo el
tablero que estamos exponiendo
absolutamente pero es que a pesar de
toda la crisis de la crisis del 73 de la
crisis del año 90 económica de la crisis
del 2008-2009 la trayectoria de nuestra
dependencia energética de los fósiles a
medida que ha aumentado el consumo o la
demanda energética las proporciones han
sido la misma el carbón el gas y el
petróleo son las principales fuentes de
demanda
línea de arriba es la energía biomasa
hidráulica y renovable así que si podéis
ver proporcionalmente el mix energético
mundial no ha cambiado en los otros 50
años se produce muchísima más energía
renovable por supuesto estamos en récord
cada año sin embargo el aumento de la
demanda es tan importante que a pesar de
que se duplique en la instalación de
paneles solares y de turbinas la demanda
hace que seamos dependientes del gas y
del petróleo
sin remedio parece entonces pues hay que
hay que reducir por supuesto el malgasto
de energía está clarísimo luego vamos a
hablar del largo plazo pero antes para
atajar el problema de inflación estamos
viendo planes de choque en distintos
países por ejemplo reducir unos céntimos
el precio de los carburantes que es
energéticos y luego de países como
alemania que incluso se preparan quizá
para lo que hasta ahora ha sido un tabú
el racionamiento del gas los cortes los
llamados cortes como ven esos planes de
urgencias y a grosso modo de lo que
estamos viendo por ejemplo la subvención
lineal al carburante emilio si es
posible ayudar las personas en
obviamente es lo que hay que hacer los
cortes lamentablemente para mi red
resucitan traumas de la adolescencia en
venezuela y
lamentablemente si tocara hacerlo me
imagino que será la solución pero espero
que no tengan por qué llegar a esos
extremos lo grande que es que claro un
plan de emergencia como su propio nombre
indica hablemos del corto plazo y el
corto plazo de perfección tiene poco
todas las soluciones que vayamos a
encontrar el corto plazo imagino no son
las más adecuadas
de hecho hay muy pocas soluciones a muy
corto plazo porque no hemos reducido la
demanda de energía en los últimos años
la solución rápida pero drástica no es
reducir el consumo de energía con la
interrupción del consumo de energía de
algunas empresas industriales y en el
peor de los casos casos las aplicación
de cortes
rotativos la otra solución rápida es
utilizar los centrales eléctricas de
carbón como se hacen en la baña y en
francia con la zanja de codeme y santa
bold
este es por supuesto una antítesis de la
transición en la región
el problema está que y lo estamos viendo
cada día en eeuu se han acelerado los
permisos de explotación de fuentes de
petróleo y de gases con lo cual estamos
ante un riesgo el secretario general de
la naciones unidad hablaba el otro día
de que la crisis de ucrania no se está
poniendo en un camino donde avanzamos
con los ojos vendados hacia la
catástrofe climática porque por supuesto
la seguridad energética es la prioridad
pero el problema es que con estas
infraestructuras de explotación y no
olvidemos que ahora el gas licuado hay
que
liquidarlo y luego hay que regasificarlo
son infraestructuras que cuando se
construyen están ahí para durar décadas
vamos a hacer una breve pausa en este
punto y en unos instantes les vuelvo a
dar la palabra y seguimos analizando
toda esta situación aquí en primera
plana hasta ahora
[Música]
la guerra está a las puertas de europa y
recuerda horas sombrillas de la historia
la comunidad se organizado para darles
ropa
france24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en ucrania
con nuestros equipos en el terreno y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
liberté égalité actual y de
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
seguimos en primera plana de radio
france internacional y de france 24 esta
semana analizando la crisis energética
derivada de la guerra de ucrania le
hacemos con el hombre manuel rubio
abogada especializada en energía emilio
de la riva ingeniero geofísico y mi
compañera periodista especializada en
medio ambiente mariana castaño bueno
antes de la pausa lo comentamos algunos
países como alemania e incluso hablan de
racionamiento del gas
berlín ha dado un primer paso formal que
consiste en activar la fase de alerta
temprana de su ley de emergencia creada
para hacer frente a la escasez de este
combustible del que dependen en gran
medida su potente industria y las
calefacciones de 83 millones de
habitantes y no sé si la pregunta quizás
sea desde a nivel consumidor y antes
emilio lo evocaba un poco estamos
preparados nuestras sociedades están
preparadas estos llamados al ahorro
energético
totalmente o sea nadie estaba preparado
a un confinamiento casi de un día para
otros y de repente lo tuvimos que hace
dos años hemos confinamiento si vamos
puede que lleguemos al corte al corte de
suministro algo impensable para una
sociedad
hasta ayer totalmente pero se nos
cortaron las libertades de movimiento
está claro que en una situación de
crisis mayor la población tiene que
someterse a lo que dicten en este caso
los estados por el bien por el bien
común en donde cortamos el gasto lo
cortamos solo para la calefacción y le
decimos en las personas que usen abrigos
en sus casas o lo cortemos para
electricidad y cortamos directamente a
la electricidad también hay que plantear
esto porque son cosas bastante
diferentes creo que ahora hay que decir
antes hablamos de la solución del gas
licuado siguiendo con el ejemplo alemán
precisamente se están acelerando la
construcción de plantas regasificadoras
en su territorio antes hablamos del más
corto plazo vayamos a algo más medio
plazo para poder recibir gas natural
licuado y se negocia contratos con otros
proveedores o qué ventajas
inconvenientes tienen este tipo de
soluciones por ejemplo el gas licuado al
que te quería referir antes los estados
undos van a aumentar su entregas de gas
natural licuado para suministrar europa
sin embargo en términos concretos
éste ayuda teóricamente permitiera a
reemplazar una décima sólo una décima
parte del gas ruso previsto para todos
y
una tercera parte para los años
siguientes sin embargo el mercado de gas
natural licuado está limitado por muchas
razones número de bujes número de
terminar el dedique facción número de
terminales de regasificación y contrato
de larga duración que suministra la
mayor parte del hacia países europeos
como alemania y francia- contarán con
nuevas terminales de importación de gas
natural licuado
o sea que vemos que es una solución que
tampoco que también tiene
negativa porque el transporte del gas
licuado implica que tiene tres veces más
huella de carbono porque para pasar del
estado gaseoso al estado líquido y de
nuevo al estado gaseoso se necesita
enfriarlo a menos 160 grados y
mantenerlo frío en eso en esos tanques
en esos barcos gigantescos que vienen y
como decía lo que lo que va a ser una
solución entre comillas para la
emergencia va a ser un problema desde el
punto de vista climático porque esas
infraestructuras llegan para quedarse
desgraciadamente ahí tienen la clave del
programa que les estamos proponiendo hoy
la emergencia a corto plazo cómo puede
entrar en colisión con la transición
energética quizás la gran pregunta a
resolver emilio es completamente
irreconciliable la independencia
energética y la ecología aunque el 'mix
energético' contenga una dosis
importante de renovables
o no queremos hablar de la palabra
irreconciliable
hay que replantearse bastante bueno
justamente el tema de por qué porque en
rusia sería ésta la perfecta relación
amor-odio bueno porque tenemos los
gasoductos ya directamente no tiene que
pasar por ningún nuestros procesos pero
ahora tocará replantearse realmente qué
es la la dependencia energética porque
también bueno algo que yo que yo siempre
veo
ciertamente el uranio por lo menos de
francia los tramos otros países pero
también por vernos los paneles solares
tienen ciertos componentes que no
traemos aquí entonces al final como lo
decía es el tejido es el sistema estamos
todos conectados y en el momento que uno
de los de las piezas se cae
no sabemos que hay que relocalizar la
producción energética y como sabemos que
las minas de carbón o no son eficaces o
por supuesto son un gravísimo problema
para el medio ambiente relocalizar la
producción energética pasa por
inversiones masivas en la renovables y
en la eficacia energética porque se
pierden y vosotros estáis mejor situados
que yo por vuestra vuestra experiencia
profesional se pierde muchísima energía
en los edificios en los procesos
industriales y en el transporte así que
la eficaz y la renovable y la
electrificación es fundamental hablando
de buenos ahora si en francia hemos
tomaron muchas medidas para acelerar la
renovación energética de los edificios
pero tardan mucho en pillar su partido
es muy costosas por mucho que incluso
haya ventajas fiscales a la hora de
tomar pero hay incentivos pero claro el
tiempo el tiempo no juega a nuestro
favor
en toda esta transición energética y
menos lacito de la coyuntura actualmente
otro elemento que hay que sumar y que no
podemos eludir qué papel debe jugar
nuclear en toda esta situación es
complicado abrir este debate ahora
porque es poner los elementos nos
llevaría a un programa entero pero si la
coyuntura ha venido un poco a respaldar
un poco quizá viéndolo desde fuera la
posición de francia no respecta a tener
una dependencia menor gracias a lo
nuclear es un debate complicado pero a
día de hoy quizá la pregunta hoy en día
es posible un 'mix energético' verde sin
la participación de lo nuclear en una
sociedad con niveles de consumo y
economía como la francesa es posible hoy
en día de hoy para mañana no por
supuesto y por eso francia
ha pasado de tener una política de no
dar si no darle vida a las centrales
antiguas a construir nuevos generadores
y no es el único no es el único porque
la transición energética y lo hemos
visto en esta curva es muy difícil es
muy difícil porque los miembros con los
que está construido nuestro sistema
social y económico están basados en el
carbón en el carbón después en gas y
petróleo y de eso de hace 250 años ya
necesitamos una no una transición ni una
transformación estamos una revolución y
para eso hay que invertir masivamente en
los renovables y la electrificación y de
investir des investir es decir los
subsidios que se dan a los combustibles
fósiles porque no olvidemos que los
combustibles fósiles son rentables
porque están altamente subsidiados por
los estados están impidiendo la
transición energética lo cual es noble
discurso muy peligroso
también el almacenamiento energía que
también es algo que también es el
hidrógeno por ejemplo esas son varias
cosas que se han estado dando poco a
poco pero que no vamos a conseguir por
ejemplo la fusión nuclear no la mojando
un momento para otros son procesos
bastante lentos y podemos pensar en el
corto plazo no logramos encontrar la
solución
llegado este punto me gustaría
plantearles un ejercicio para todos
nuestros oyentes y espectadores que nos
estén viendo dado una situación como la
que tenemos ahora mismo como preparamos
un hogar que buenos gestos o una empresa
para una crisis energética como para
superarla como ahora me gustaría hacer
una ronda que que pudiéramos fijar un
pequeño gesto algo en casa que podemos
decir vaya ahí porque eso es parte de lo
que estamos hablando de mariana ver
bueno cuando empezó cuando empezaron los
tambores de guerra
ucrania entre ucrania y rusia estamos al
principio del invierno ahora tenemos
bueno la suerte por así decirlo que
estamos ya saliendo a pesar de la ola de
frío que tenemos ahora mismo en europa
con lo cual ya tenemos ahí una ventaja
en europa muchos de los espectadores que
nos están viendo el justo están en el
hemisferio sur y están en el ciclo
contrario pero también vale los consejos
son iguales para todos yo había apagado
la calefacción en mi casa precisamente
por por bueno para poder ahorrar energía
y desgraciadamente estamos ha logrado
en parís la he tenido que volver a subir
pero básicamente bajando no uno yo
animaría a bajar dos grados la
temperatura en las casas allí donde
donde se esté utilizando por ustedes
montado y ponerse ropa o ponerse ropa
bajar durante el día a los 18 grados
durante la noche se puede dormir a 16
grados estando bien abrigados por
supuesto también el gasto de energía va
ligado a los metros cuadrados ya la
densidad de población de cada vivienda
entonces bueno pues si en caso extremo y
en alemania antes de que empezara la
invasión rusa de ucrania ya se invitó a
la gente a la familia bueno si hay una
familia que está con los abuelos en una
casa y los padres en otra casa bueno
pues a lo mejor hay que pasar unos días
todo junto en una casa y apagar la
calefacción del segundo domicilio son
medidas que se pueden por sombras para
evitar el drama que sería que paramos la
industria para para no cortar la
electricidad los hogares empezarían por
la industria y tener tu verdad y la
electricidad en los hogares hay medidas
que se puedan tomar
si estoy de acuerdo con lo que las
semillas que alguna que podamos apuntar
o emilio a ver si hay alguna difícil
está difícil tema de calefacción ha sido
ha sido como lo más
que he visto tengo amigos por lo menos
que vienen alemania y apenas comenzó el
conflicto dijeron yo la calefacción la
pago yo intenté durante gran parte del
invierno no usar calefacción
estar bastante abrigado en casa y
funcionó para el tema las industrias
podría ser un poquito más complicado
eléctrico bueno por ejemplo el stand by
no tantos electrodomésticos que tenemos
en casa conectados con con el stand by
que a veces nos vamos de vacaciones y
los podemos dejar un algo en standby lo
que puede consumir la moda de vida son
un coladero de energía o sea no nos
damos cuenta porque durante muchísimos
años lo hemos asumido cuando era barato
era barato y desde hace un año al
principio fue el rebote por la pandemia
tras la pandemia en la recuperación
económica y ahora la la guerra y falta
de incentivos
de correctivos de información falta
información porque no sabemos que
nuestras casas nuestros modos de vida
son auténticos coladeros energéticos
pero esta tierra de ucrania precisamente
todo el tema y hacer por ejemplo este
programa también sensibiliza mucho de
darnos cuenta de todo el tiempo que
hemos vivido siendo coladores de energía
no hay como una toma de conciencia yo sí
que lo veo no no no ven esa toma de
conciencia de energética yo creo que se
ve cuando la conversación es cuánto
pagaste por sí por supuesto cuando nos
tocan el bolsillo la conciencia va allá
y dice le haga esto es esto en serio
creo que ahí es cuando se conoce bien a
ver entonces por eso bueno creo que
incentivos podría hacerlo lo más
positivo porque al final siempre podemos
llevarnos golpes llegar los golpes y de
repente no lo vemos así pero cuando nos
dice mira si tú haces esta medida que
está aquí vas a recibir por este lado no
sé si puede ser
dinerito extra creo que las medidas
buenos ya eso es de los políticos para
tomarlo pero creo que hay que hay que
enfocarse en eso ayudar más a los que
ahorran básicamente luego quiere ese
punto algo más
porque hay que pensar por supuesto en
las casas porque en europa las
calefacciones en gran parte son a base
de gas pero luego hay que pensar también
en el transporte cómo nos transportamos
a nuestro lugar de trabajo a nuestro
lugar de estudio cuando tuvimos la
pandemia y el confinamiento hubo una
bajada del uso individual de transporte
brutal porque claro nos teníamos que
quedar en casa algunos teletrabajando y
otros en paro directamente en este
momento podría porque el vimos que se
pudo hace dos años se podría volver a un
sistema de teletrabajo y eso implicaría
una reducción muy muy importante en el
uso del automóvil
me quedo ya sin tiempo muchísimas
gracias a los tres ha sido un placer
contar con ustedes para analizar la
crisis energética derivada de la guerra
de ucrania muchísimas gracias ahora
emilio mariana y a todos ustedes les
esperamos aquí en primera plana la
próxima semana muchas gracias
[Música]